- [Voiceover] So we have
the function g of x,
which is equal to 2/x to
the third minus 1/x squared.
And what I wanna do in this video,
is I wanna find what g prime of x is
and then I also wanna
evaluate that at x equal two,
so I wanna figure that out.
And I also wanna figure out what does
that evaluate to when x is equal to two?
So what is the slope
the of the tangent line
to the graph of g, when x is equal to two?
And like always, pause this video and
see if you can work this out on your own
before I work through it with you.
And I'll give you some hints
all you really need to do is
apply the power rule, a little bit of
basic exponent properties
and some basic derivative properties
to be able to do this.
Alright, now let's just do this together
and I'll just rewrite it.
G of x is equal to this first term here,
2/x to the third.
Well, that could be rewritten as
2 times x to the negative three.
We know that 1/x to
the n is the same thing
as x to the negative n.
So I just rewrote it and this might
be ringing a bell of how the power rule
might be useful.
And then we have minus-
well, 1/x squared that is the same thing
as x to the negative two.
And so this, if we're gonna take
the derivative of both sides of this,
let's do that.
Derivative with respect to x.
Dx, we're gonna do that
on the left-hand side,
we're also gonna do it
on the right-hand side.
On the left-hand side, the derivative
with respect to x of g of x,
we can write that as g prime of x
is going to be equal to,
well, the derivative of this first
that we have right here written in green,
this is going to be, we're just gonna
apply the power rule.
We're going to take our exponent,
multiply it by our coefficient out front,
actually let me write that out,
that's going to be...
There's this equal sign.
That is going to be two
times negative three,
times x and now we're going
to decrement this exponent.
You have to be very careful here
because sometimes your brain might say,
"Okay, one less than three is two,
"so maybe this is x in the negative two."
but remember, you're going down.
So if you're at negative
three and you subtract one,
we're gonna go with the negative three
minus one power.
We'll that's gonna take
us to negative four.
So this is x to the negative four power.
So two times negative three
x to the negative four,
or we could have also written that as
negative six x to the negative four power.
And then, minus...
Well, we're gonna do the same thing again
right over here.
We take this negative two, multiply it by
the coefficient that's implicitly here,
you could say there's a one there.
So negative two times one.
So you have the negative two there
and then you have the x to the-
well what's a negative two minus one?
That's negative three.
To the negative three power.
And so we can rewrite
all of this business as,
the derivative g prime of x,
is equal to negative six,
negative six x to the negative fourth.
And now we're subtracting a negative.
So we could just write this as,
plus two x to the negative three.
This negative cancels
out with that negative.
Subtract a negative, same
thing as adding a positive.
So we did the first part.
We can express g prime
of x as a function of x.
Now, let's just evaluate
what g prime of two is.
So g prime of two is going to be equal to
negative six times two to
the negative fourth power
plus two times two to
the negative third power.
Well, what's this going to be?
This is equal to negative
6/2 to the fourth,
plus 2/2 to the third,
which is equal to negative six over-
two to the fourth is 16,
plus 2/2 to the third is eight.
And so let's see, this is...
Lets rewrite this all
with a common denominator.
I could write this as 1/4,
but then this one won't
work out as cleanly,
I could write them both as eights.
This is negative 3/8s.
Negative 3/8s.
So you have negative 3/8s plus two eights
is equal to negative 1/8.
So the slope of the tangent
line at x equals two,
to the graph y equals g of x has a slope.
That slope is negative 1/8.